training a machine learning model
involves testing a variety of parameters
to figure out which configuration works
best
before you even start training a model
you'll need to setup some hyper
parameters like the number of epochs you
want to train for or the type of
optimization function you want to use
but it can be tricky to figure out which
values it will give you the results you
want let's take a look at what hyper
parameters are and how cat tip can help
you tune them
[Applause]
today we'll talk about hyper parameters
and how to use captive for hyper
parameter tuning if you want to check
out the documentation directly check out
the link below to read more about Kat
tube and how to use it
unlike the training parameters that are
tested and adjusted during the training
phase hyper parameters aren't learned by
the model they're provided before you
begin training and can make a big impact
on the results of your model you could
try adjusting them yourself changing
hyper parameters and noting the results
but when you have many different
configurations you want to explore and
training your model takes a significant
amount of time it's not feasible to do
it yourself that's where Kats app comes
in to help Kat tip helps tune your hyper
parameters by testing a range of values
for each one you need to define what
your objective is and then set up an
experiment so CAD tip can try different
hyper parameter values for example if
you are trading a model with two hyper
parameters learning rate and batch size
and wanted to maximize the accuracy Kat
dip could run the experiment to try
different values and see how they affect
your objective you could also try
different objectives like minimizing
error rate let's walk through actually
running captain you can try this out for
yourself if you have a cute little
instance running just head to the
dashboard choose your namespace and then
click Kat tube on the left side followed
by hyper parameter tuning this should
give you a big text box where you can
paste a yeah mol file will include a
link in the description for the one
we're using here so go ahead and copy
face the file here and then hit deploy
this can take a while to run so let's
take a look at some of the configuration
we're specifying here we're defining
some key values with our trial counts
each trial is an iteration through the
experiment with one set of hyper
parameter values this whole file will
create one experiment with twelve trials
as specified in a max trial account in
addition cueball will run three trials
in parallel thanks to the parallel trial
count and max failed trial count will
shut down the experiment if three of the
trials result in failure in addition
we're also specifying the objective
we're looking for in this case we want
to maximize the accuracy one metric a
goal of 0.99 is also specified so the
experiment will automatically stop if we
hit 99% accuracy
lastly we can specify which algorithm
cat tip will use to tune the hyper
parameter values multiple algorithms are
supported such as grid search or a
Bayesian optimization but we'll keep
things
simple with the random algorithm in this
case ketchup will randomly try different
values for our hyper parameters and
measure our objective metric let's take
a look at the hyper parameters in the
configuration file these are the actual
hyper parameters we want to test in this
case we're looking at testing the
learning rate and batch size for our
training step each hyper parameter has a
type along with the feasible range of
values with minimums and maximums since
we've specified random as our algorithm
cat tip we'll choose random values for
these two inside the feasible space and
then run the training job as a single
trial once we've hit the max trial count
our experiments should be finished we
can check the status by selecting the
menu icon next to cat Tim and choosing
HP then monitor you'll see a list of any
experiment and their current status a
checkmark means the experiment has
completed successfully and we can click
on it to see more information this graph
can look a little bit complicated but
it's actually just showing you each
trial over the entire experiment the
left column is the result of our
objective metric the middle column is a
learning rate and the right column is
our batch size if we look at the line
that had the highest accuracy we can see
the values of our hyper parameters that
leads to this run it can be a bit hard
to see the exact values here so if you
scroll down you can see a table with all
the trials looks like the best learning
rate was around point zero one one one
and the batch size was 170 giving us an
accuracy of just over 97% in this case
we only used 12 trials but we can easily
change the mo file and try another
experiment with more trials or
additional hyper parameters cat SAV can
help save you a lot of time and effort
and narrowing down the best values for
your hyper parameters and is easy to set
up an experiment try it out for yourself
and check out the documentation to read
more
[Music]
[Applause]